hello everyone welcome to the mindscape
podcast I'm your host Sean Carroll you
have the right to remain silent we are
told here in the United States this is
part of the famous Miranda warning that
is given to newly arrested suspects to
remind them of some of their rights as
enumerated in the U.S Constitution
especially the Fifth Amendment the right
against self-incrimination and this is
actually pretty common practice around
the world that suspects cannot be forced
to testify against themselves it's
supposed to protect You Against torture
or forced confessions anything like that
and there's other aspects of rights that
we have in the U.S Constitution and
elsewhere that for example very famously
in Roe v Wade the U.S Supreme Court said
that there was implicitly a right to
privacy in the U.S Constitution given
all the enumerated rights it was
sensible to say that these added up to a
right to privacy your opinions of that
that particular judgment May differ but
the idea that governments cannot simply
see everything we're doing read all of
our emails tap all of our phone
conversations Etc it is pretty well
entrenched and for good reason but what
if the government could just read your
mind
what then are the limits that protect
our right to privacy if a government
could somehow know what you are thinking
that might sound science fictiony but
it's less science fictiony than you
might think because the technology is
advancing today's podcast is not going
to be primarily about the technology
although we'll discuss that it's going
to be about the ethical and legal
implications of neurotechnology of the
idea that we can have brain scanning
devices that tell a listener something
about what a person is thinking at
different levels of specificity not even
necessarily an imp plant but in some
cases as we'll hear
earphones are being sold that you can
use while gaming to help get signals
directly from your brain without having
to use your fingers to use your mouse or
your keyboard or anything like that
there are a lot of reasons why such
technology might be very very attractive
to a lot of people they're going to do
it to themselves and they're giving away
information about their thoughts to a
corporation or perhaps to the government
today's guest is Nita farahani who is
both a law professor and a bioethicist
and in her new book The Battle for your
brain defending the right to think
freely in an age of neurotechnology
she's looking ahead to what are going to
be the legal and ethical skirmishes over
the collection and use of this
information as we've seen in much more
benign circumstances human beings in the
Modern Age with social media Etc are
remarkably unconcerned about the their
privacy they will give away a huge
amount of data to corporations and to
the government for a little bit of
convenience and the idea is that new
technology is going to make this bargain
even more attractive and even more
pervasive so what are we going to do
about it what are we going to do when in
principle the government might be able
to read your political inclinations to
know that you're planning a crime to
imagine or notice that you have hateful
thoughts one way or the other what about
companies that want to hire you or fire
you or schools that want to give you
grades or something like that on the
basis of just scanning what's in your
brain it's a very different world coming
up obviously right now we can't do this
to anything like this kind of precision
but it's not crazy to think that it will
be coming soon and the time to think
about it is now so let's go
[Music]
thank you
Anita Farah honey welcome to the
mindscape podcast thanks for having me
we're gonna go a distance here through
law and ethics and technology and all
sorts of crazy futuristic things so just
to get people grounded right from the
start the the problem seems to be that
if governments or corporations could
read our minds that would lead to Legal
complications is that the safe way of
getting it I would say like legal and
social complications so you know if
governments and corporations can read
our minds and change our minds not just
read them uh that we should be worried
about that what means what that means
for the future of humanity change our
minds what are you referring to there I
mean the ability to manipulate and hack
or even you know use weapons to disable
mines on battlefields yep that sounds
important to understand and yeah I guess
I was going to ask this much later in
the podcast let me just say it right now
you know
the authors of the Constitution weren't
worrying about this right no no they
were not they were not I mean you know
if you look back at the way laws and
whether that's U.S based laws or
international human laws or
international human rights rights laws
were written
nobody really contemplated a world in
which you could actually hack and track
the human brain everybody assumed that
it was your private Diaries or your
spoken words that we needed to be
worried about or your actions not what
you're thinking or feeling and it just
turns out that that world has arrived
and we need to really update how we
think about laws and protections for
Humanity in order to ensure that it
continues to be a world in which we want
to live in well which raises the very
basic question for people who would ever
write laws or write the Constitution I
mean to what extent should we be
enshrining the very basic principles
versus attempting to foresee every
possible application of them
yeah I think it's difficult if not
impossible to foresee every possible
application and misapplication of a
technology and oftentimes technology
advances much more quickly than laws and
regulations can so the approach that
I've advocated for is what I call a
right to cognitive Liberty a broad
update to our understanding of Liberty
and to do that at the international
human rights level to both create laws
but also Norms about the right to
self-determination over our brains and
mental experiences and I think if we
start there it changes the default rules
our default rule is protection over our
right self-determination of our brains
and mental experiences which means laws
have to be created or policies have to
be created as exceptions to that for
corporations to gain access to our brain
data or for governments to gain access
to it
um and to manipulate it for that matter
so so I think it changes the starting
place of the conversation
to start there and then you know we're
going to need contact specific laws and
regulations over time you know how are
these devices used in employment
settings how are these devices used by
governments whether it's in the military
or you know even for things like trying
to use Biometrics from the brain to
authenticate people or using the
technology for interrogating criminals
to try to figure out what they're
concealing in their minds but but I
think we have to start by changing the
default rules in favor of individuals
good so let's let's step back then and
consider the technological landscape
here even before getting to the more
science fictiony things like there are
ways in which we have the technology to
see or perceive what are in people's
brains right now I mean at the at the
dumbest level we've invented a whole
bunch of ways where people can just spew
their unveettered thoughts out there
into the internet and social media which
sort of gives people a lot of
information already
that's true and if you spend a lot of
time on social media you might think
that those are unfiltered thoughts and
that they just come straight from
people's brains rather than you know
some kind of filter or Gateway through
which they make decisions about what to
post but in actuality what's happening
is people are choosing to write
particular things and to share
particular things and to search in
search engines for particular words and
phrases and
um there are a lot of choices that we're
making and those choices that we're
making are being used to make pretty
precise profiles of who we are and how
we think and how we feel but they still
don't go as far as actually decoding
what's in your brain right there's still
you know a space in which people have
private contemplation they have the
ability to you know think thoughts that
they never share with anyone have
thoughts pop into their head about you
know a fantasy that they might have a
new idea that they want to turn over in
their mind before thinking about sharing
it with other people or even working out
their own self-identity in their own
working on their own biases working on
uh their you know kind of developing
understanding of who who they are and
those things don't hopefully show up on
social media although sometimes they do
that sometimes how people work things
out
but there's a difference right you you
choose to share versus having
information that you have not chosen to
share be used and there are ways that
that's happening already facial
recognition software can already pick up
microfacial changes
um a precise dossier can be put together
that you know triangulates your GPS
location and your financial data and
your Healthcare information and a whole
bunch of other pieces to give us a
pretty good and accurate insight into
a person but it's still not the same as
what's in your mind and so I believe
that you know there is this last Bastion
of Freedom or privacy that we have and
it's it's not just the last one that
will fall it is I think the most
important one that never should
good I do remember this is only slightly
related but a Quantum information
theorist who I know said he once figured
out a way that you could have a search
engine such that it couldn't figure out
who's doing the searching right there
was a privacy you know Quantum privacy
protocol and he pitched it to the people
at Google and they got very excited but
then they came back the next day and
they said wait a minute this is exactly
the opposite of our business models
right we do not want to let you do that
actually right but about the you know
the micro
expressions and lie detectors and things
like that I mean I know there's a TV
show lied to me with Tim Roth in it it
was a lot of fun but my impression was
the science there was a little bogus I
mean what is the state of the art and in
that kind of non-invasive you don't even
know your thoughts are being detected
kind of Technology
yeah I mean I think the science there is
still somewhat focused as you just said
right which is um there are some things
that we can tell and you know there's
some patterns of of uh facial activity
that gives you some insights at least in
the aggregate across the population but
not necessarily you know is that
accurate for any given person you know
like what if I've had Botox and you try
to read my microfacial changes how
accurate is it then right or
um you know what if I you know have I'm
trying to keep my face really still or
if I'm just different in how I express
my face I have a really good poker face
and somebody else doesn't have as good
of a poker face
um so they're still inferences and the
truth is when you're reading brain
activity they're also inferences based
on patterns and activity right it's not
literally that you are picking up
thoughts in whole form you're taking
some biological measure which is brain
States and brain activity changes in
electrical activity and using algorithms
that are then trying to decode what that
means but the bigger the data sets are
with human brain activity the better and
more precise it becomes and you know
with with tools like generative AI that
can be used to be trained on any
particular person's brain activity it
gets more and more and more precise over
time to decode what's actually in a
particular person's brain so we have we
actually go out and spend money to buy
devices that monitor our location and
our physiological state right exercise
bands and things like that
um and presumably that is actually right
now being used to build up precise
profiles I mean I mean you're the you're
the law expert here
um do the companies who gather all that
data and collate it do they promise not
to keep track of which individual it is
or they're very interested in keeping
track of which individual it is I think
they're very interested in keeping track
on which individual it is but more more
importantly I think it is
trying to figure out you know so it may
not be that efficient to Market to a
particular person right customize it
down to where you have one particular
person that you're marketing to but the
more that you can segment the population
right this is a you know person who
lives in the following demographics who
has the following kinds of jobs who has
the following kinds of purchasing
Behavior who has you know X number of
kids of the following ages and spends
this much amount of time on social media
right the more carefully you can segment
the population the more precisely you
can Target advertisements to it and so
that is what most big Tech corporations
have built their models on is not only
um aggregating data but then selling to
advertisers a promise of real Precision
about targeting of advertisements right
it's not very effective to send weight
loss targeted advertisements to somebody
who's trying to gain weight you really
need to find somebody who is trying to
lose weight in order to send those types
of advertisements so the better you can
Target the advertisements presumably the
better conversion you have to actually
purchasing things
and you know and so the question is what
does brain data add does it add
something new and there are a whole
bunch of companies called neuro
marketing companies and even major
corporations now who have neuro
marketing divisions and these are
divisions that recognize that what
consumers say about what they're likely
to do in response to advertisements or
pricing of products or what a product
looks like the trade dress of it is not
as accurate as what their brains say
when shown those different things
um and so self-reporting has long been a
problem for marketers and so if you can
base it on behavioral data instead and
particularly on brain based Behavior
right how does the brain show engagement
or fear or excitement or
um you know is it does a person pay
attention actually throughout the entire
advertisement that you play or do they
does their mind start to wander halfway
through
um so those are kinds those are the
kinds of insights that neuromarketing
companies have been offering now to
corporations for a long time by using
neurotechnology simple consumer-based
wearable devices where while people are
watching advertisements or seeing
products or seeing different pricing of
products
the companies are measuring how their
brain reacts to those products then
using that to create insights about the
next marketing campaign but this is more
like a focus group this is not like
something they're able to do to every
person who walks by a billboard or so
forth that's right
um so you know because brain wearables
are not ubiquitous and it's people who
have opted into wearing them or you know
you don't have to do this even in
Laboratories anymore people have
consumer-based devices at home and they
can go on to these websites that will
pay them to have their brain waves
monitored while they look at different
advertisements but they've opted in and
they've opted into sharing that data
they're getting paid to share that data
neural marketing is or building it based
on that data they may not need to do so
in a world in which you know there is
wide scale brain wearables in our
everyday devices so we're wearing
headphones right now the you know this
coming uh spring there's one of the
major neural marketing companies who's
partnered with one of the major
headphone manufacturers to take the soft
cups around our ears and fill those full
of uh brain sensors that can pick up the
electrical activity in the brain and so
while you're recording a podcast or
while you're taking a conference call or
listening to music your brain activity
can be monitored at the same time and
you know somebody might say like well
why would anybody choose that headset
instead of one that doesn't have those
brain sensors
and I think it's because of the promise
that we'll offer for the individual
which is you know they can interact with
the rest of their technology seamlessly
they can track their focus and attention
they can track their brain health just
like they track their heart rate they
can eventually do things like replace
their mouse or their keyboard and be
able to think about moving the mouse
around the screen in a much more
seamless way or be able to communicate
much more closely at the rate of thought
rather than you know typing speed on
either a keyboard or you know worse on
with two thumbs on a smartphone you
could just think about it instead and so
as those devices come to the market and
we're all wearing these and you know
you're surfing social media
and your brain wave activity is being
recorded by the headset that you're
wearing you know the question is are
neuromarketers really going to need to
continue to have these focus groups or
our company's going to have unfettered
access to how your brain reacts to
whether they give you a b testing and
like you know person a sees their feed
in the following way person B sees their
feet in that way let's look at what
their brain activity looks like in group
a versus Group B
yeah wow so
um I do want to ask a little bit more
about the actual technology here I mean
you talk about measuring brain activity
measuring brain waves uh do we know what
it is we really want to measure and do
we have good ways of doing it
so it really just depends on what you
are trying to measure for right so
um you know even the most sophisticated
consumer neurotechnology device can't
literally read your mind there aren't
enough electrodes they're not deeply
placed inside the brain
um you know the most sophisticated
electroencephalography which measures
electrical activity in your brain as you
think or you know do a math calculation
or anything you do neurons are firing in
your brain which gives off tiny
electrical discharges
um and when hundreds of thousands of
neurons are firing at the same time when
you're doing something those create
patterns that can be decoded so this is
what it looks like when you're you know
thinking about a word this is what it
looks like when you're thinking about a
face and then it can get much more
precise from there to you know kind of
recreate an image that you're looking at
but unless you have a broad array of
electrodes implanted deeply inside the
brain how much information you're
getting out of the brain is not that
much and you have interference and you
know clinical grade EEG which was like a
cap people can Envision this right
there's a fitted cap that you wear that
has 128 electrodes on it and each one
has to be applied to the scalp precisely
with gel in order to get good
conductance
um that's not what we're talking about
we're talking about like earphones or
earbuds or tiny tattoos worn behind your
ear that have somewhere between two and
you know maybe 30 electrodes and they
are making dry contact with the skin and
they have good applications to support
making sure that they're in the right
place but you know everybody might have
them adjusted slightly differently from
one another so you know exactly what
it's picking up is going to vary a
little bit between person and person
but despite that then the question is
what can you pick up and you're picking
up depending on where you are where the
electrode is attached you're picking up
electric activity from the brain from
these firing of neurons that rise to the
level of the scalp that can be detected
then you're averaging it usually over
the different number of electrodes that
you have
and you know you can measure things
already
you know companies have have uh
developed the ability to track things
like attention or Focus or mind
wandering
um basic emotional states happy sad
um even some things like numbers or
shapes that you're seeing or imagining
can be reconstructed
um even you know some Studies have shown
that EEG as a person is looking at a
face that it's possible to reconstruct
the face that they're seeing
um and so you know the Precision is
increasing every day even with
consumer-based electrodes and basic
health patterns can also be detected an
epileptic may have a signature of change
in the electrical activity in their
brain an hour before they have an
epileptic seizure when a person develops
a horrible brain tumor called a
glioblastoma the earliest stages of that
show tiny changes in electrical activity
that continuous use of a headset like
these could pick up so so there's a lot
that can be picked up and in my book the
battle for your brain I go through
so many examples of what's already
happening as well as the research using
consumer neurotechnology I'm not taking
from you know the most sophisticated
implanted electrodes to say that's what
we can do in today's world instead I'm
drawing from study after study after
study to show what's actually happening
today what can be decoded from the brain
right now
and it's both terrific and terrifying
how much can already be decoded from the
human brain using simple surface-based
electrodes it does seem like very
fertile ground for exactly the kind of
machine learning deep learning
techniques that help computers
distinguish pictures of cats from
pictures of dogs right like you can get
a set of neurode
um
uh sorry what are the what are the
connections
uh the neurons sorry no yeah what are
the electrodes that is that is it a
number of electrodes that we're counting
here yeah yeah so it's electrodes on the
surface of the scalp you know
yeah so the electrodes are getting some
signal and the human being doesn't know
what it is we just train it on a big
enough data set that's computer can
figure out exactly what it is yeah yeah
that's part of why there have been such
tremendous advances in consumer
neurotechnology as of recently is it's
really both the miniaturization and
improvements of the electrodes and the
sensors themselves but also an
incredibly importantly the advances in
computational you know um computational
skills from algorithms and machine
learning that have just made seismic
advances and the more brain data that we
have while people are engaged in their
everyday activities and you have that
right so you say
um okay algorithm here's what the brain
activity looks like this is what the
person was looking at or this is what
the person was listening to or you know
this is what the person was thinking of
typing that's just data that you know
huge patterns of you know data that
machine learning algorithms can be
trained on and and the extraordinary
advances that have been made in Ai and
continue to be made in AI I mean
generative AI is going to lead to
another huge leap in this technology
means that suddenly what seemed like
science fiction a few years ago is
science reality today of how much we can
decode from the human brain do we have
anything like a good picture of which
kinds of thoughts can be read are there
some kinds of thoughts or emotions that
are going to be invisible to these
electrodes no matter how hard we look
I think
talking about surface-based electrodes
that are few in Number the likelihood of
ever decoding
unintentionally communicated complex
thought is low okay and so by that I
mean
um you know you're you're sitting there
and and you're literally having an inner
dialogue that you never intend to type
or communicate that really detailed
inner dialogue I don't see surface-based
electrodes ever decoding now you know
check back with me in five years okay
I'll eat my words right
um but it's just it's hard to imagine
getting good enough signal from deep
enough in the brain and distributed
across the brain to decode that level of
accuracy and precision
that being said you know I I when people
say you know can these read my mind I
always say well what do you think that
means to you to read your mind
um you know you uh walk in to your
friend's house and they have a really
hideous mustard yellow new couch that
they spent a lot of money to buy and
they say do you like it and you know
your face you keep as a poker face and
you're thinking oh my gosh I hate that
right and you're feeling like disgust
and
um that disgust can be picked up from
brain activity right and so your true
sentiment can be decoded even if your
precise words or your precise thoughts
can't be and so I think it just depends
on what level of specificity we're
talking about for whether or not we can
read your mind we can pick up a lot of
your sentiments and then use other
things about you to have a much much
more precise you know picture of what
you're thinking or feeling but I don't
see like literally thought bubbles above
your head decoding the full enter
dialogue with Precision with
consumer-based neurotechnology and there
there are other consumer-based neurode
technologies that could hit the Market
within a few years like Brian Johnson
has been developing
um a helmet essentially that uses
something called functional near
infrared Imaging this is sort of like
beams of light that go using infrared
near infrared light that that bounces
off the tissue for for lack of better
specificity and how to describe it in
your brain that goes deep into your
brain that can decode a lot more and so
and that's meant to be a consumer
wearable device too and so I'm talking
about based on the kind of existing
technology we have today but it's it's
rapidly improving every day and the
modalities of reading brain activity are
increasing every day it sounds like
there's almost a fortunate reality to
the metaphor of like deeper thoughts
being literally deeper in the brain that
will make them harder to pick up with
these Technologies well at least with
each G but now that's nears right so I
mean if the if the bike helmet comes to
Market
um all bets are off uh and so yeah I
think with surface-based EEG your
headphones and your earbuds deeper
thoughts maybe protected uh until we
have deeper peering technology I mean I
think I don't want to give away too much
of my own inner mental life but I'm sure
that all of us have thoughts that are
not the thoughts we want to share with
the world yeah right that's right and we
filter them right and you have a lot of
thoughts that pop up and you just think
like oh that was a terrible thought I
didn't want to have that was a terrible
thought like I'm a horrible person of
course I'm not going to express that
right and so you know you're sort of
actively sometimes at war with yourself
of of being your best version of
yourself and
um constantly editing to try to rise to
the level and to the occasion and to
really be who you want to be in the
world and and you know it's unclear how
much of that filtering is going to be
picked up by brain activity versus the
base level I'm a horrible person and
that thought just popped into my head
and and so even your ability to
cultivate your own personality and your
identity and choose what you project to
other people and choose to be the best
version of yourself if you're judged on
your brain activity instead of Judge
based on your actions and your words and
what you choose to express
um it could it could really go sideways
pretty quickly it's a completely
different Human Experience we're not
training business that's right
yeah I think what we're talking about is
a transformation of what it means to be
human and to interact with other people
and to interact with the environment
around us and
you know I I just think people aren't
really aware of what a seismic shift is
already underway to what it means to be
human and they need to join the
conversation they need to learn and get
educated about what's happening
particularly in order to have a voice
and a say and how this all goes and what
happens next
um we're still at that moment where we
can make those choices I mean they're
the technology is here uh there are
already millions of these headsets
worldwide but it's not part of people's
everyday lives yet and you know it's
just now launching into multi-functional
devices like watches and headphones and
earbuds so that you know devices we
already use rather than new devices that
are unlikely to take off because they're
you know kind of Niche applications
as that starts to take place
it will become relatively quickly too
late to have the conversation and so I I
feel like we're fortunate at where we
have the moment I remember when I read
shoshana zuboff's the age of
surveillance capitalism
I thought well okay well this is really
sad but it's like it's just too late
it's already happened right it's like
this is like a
um really sad uh historical fact now
that we we've all you know ended up in
we stand in a different place now we
stand at the Forefront of Technology
that's going to transform the experience
of what it means to be human but it
hasn't like we don't have the age of
brain surveillance capitalism yet what
we have is the opportunity to put into
place the right to cognitive liberty
before that happens to shift and flip
the narrative and how this all goes from
here
say a little bit more you already said
something about what an individual's
motivation might be for giving the rest
of the world access to their thoughts uh
gaming I guess is an obvious one but
I'll let you tell us what the main ones
are
well let me first start by saying I
think people unwittingly give access to
information without often thinking about
it and so I'll give one quick anecdote
of that which is
um Ikea a few years ago decided to do a
campaign where
um they were selling these limited
edition rugs they had partnered with
famous artists and they wanted to bring
art to everyone and so the idea was
create these limited edition rugs that
were based on art that was created in
partnership with these artists and then
sell them at Ikea based pricing to make
it available to the average consumer but
what they found was that instead of
doing that instead of democratizing
science that instead people were coming
in and they were buying the rugs and
then they were reselling them for much
higher prices on eBay right and so they
were bummed about this and they wanted
to figure out a way around it so they
launched this campaign we're in their
Brussels store people would come into
the store they could look at the rugs
but they had to put on an EEG headset a
consumer EEG headset and only if their
brains registered love for the rugs
could they buy them
and everybody who came in like happily
put on one of these little headsets and
looked at the rugs and you know they
have a little campaign commercial that
they created on this where you know they
say everybody loved it okay okay well
meaning everybody loved the experiment
not necessarily the rugs
um and you know I I look at that and I
think I I get it I like people are going
into museums and they're putting on EEG
headsets already in order to
um have their brain activity decoded as
to whether or not they love particular
art or not and then to have more art
served up according to what their brain
loves so so the fact that people are
doing this already without thinking or
questioning what is happening to my
brain data and what else are they
picking up means first they're not aware
of what they're actually signing up for
and second they're not thinking about
the broader implications of what could
it mean for this to be widespread and
adopted in that way it's already in
classrooms students are already using it
for focus and concentration parents are
already using it with their children to
help them with their focus and
concentration and neurofeedback and
meditation
so I think part of it is that people
adopt technology without recognizing or
thinking about the broader implications
of the technology
what are some of the applications people
are adopting it for one is gaming two is
neural sensors or brain sensors are
being embedded into a lot of virtual
reality headsets and I see the Next
Generation you know entering into VR
where the interface the way that they
move around VR is seamless because it's
picking up brain activity and intention
to move without thinking about oh we've
just crossed this final frontier of
privacy I think if you have the option
of a smart watch and a smart watch with
a heart sensor many people choose the
SmartWatch with the heart sensor because
it gives them the benefit of tracking
their health and their
um you know cardiac Fitness and things
like that I think they're going to do
the same thing with brain activity where
in order to track their brain health
over time it's just an add-on feature
right it's like you can have the
headphones and the earbuds but then you
can also track your performance and your
focus over the course of the day and how
stressed you are and whether your brain
health is in trouble whether you have
signs of you know cognitive decline and
there are brain training games to
improve it to improve memory you know
people are fascinated with the ability
to engage in cognitive enhancement and
cognitive Improvement and these promise
much more precise ways to do so so I
think both unwittingly and wittingly
people will adopt the technology and
then the ability to do things like
replace your keyboard by typing by
thinking about typing you know instead
of speech to text you have brain attacks
um and you know instead of typing with
two thumbs while you're driving which is
incredibly unsafe people think about
sending a text message and they you know
send it off while they're driving
you know I think I think the
possibilities are really endless and
that
um you know the combination of not
thinking about the implications and also
being excited about the novelty and the
possibility of opening up the black box
of the brain from oneself there will be
widespread adoption of the technology
well as someone who is working very hard
to finish a book draft the idea that I
wouldn't have to type
I could just sit in front of my computer
and think about sentences and the
equations that's pretty compelling I
kind of like that idea
yeah I mean there are times where I'm I
was like as I was writing this book The
Battle for your brain I was
you know it'd be like late at night and
I'd been I had been working on a
particular chapter and I just couldn't
you know get the words out or couldn't
get the ideas out and then there I am
lying in bed I don't feel like getting
up and going and typing on my computer
but it like it comes out in like full
sentences in my brain and if I could
just you know launch an app on my phone
and just translate that and capture it
or you know how you wake up in the
middle of the night you're like oh I
should keep a journal by my bad so I can
you know write down this thought or
something or even capture what my brain
dream was you know just imagine like
flipping open your phone and just being
like okay brain to brain to text and you
just get it down and go back to sleep I
think people will be excited about that
and it might also be I haven't thought
about this very much but it might also
be the extra convenience that really
lets the metaverse virtual reality kind
of thing take off if you can just sort
of see yourself walking around in a
completely different environment
interacting with people who are
thousands of miles away without
awkward you know miles and keyboard kind
of things then you know all these dreams
about the metaverse might become a lot
more uh realizable well I would say Mark
Zuckerberg certainly thinks so right
meta acquired control Labs which was one
of the leading neurotechnology companies
that's developing EMG that is picking up
brain activity as it goes from your
brain down your arm to your wrist which
signals the intention to move or the
intention to type and they've invested
billions of dollars in bringing the
metaverse to reality but also taking
that control Labs device and turning it
into the neural interface to enable you
to interact in virtual reality where the
idea would be you don't have these
awkward and silly joysticks that you're
using to you know navigate around but
you literally are thinking about
pointing and typing or you just are
you're just moving your hands Azure in
virtual reality and it's taking that and
decoding it into the actual movement and
virtual reality so I do think that that
kind of Technology as well as the neural
sensors embedded into the you know
headsets themselves will be
transformational for VR I also think
that that will lead to normalization in
the next generation of the technology
because you know the the younger
generation who will be the first to
really grow up in the metaverse if you
know the metaverse comes to fruition if
it's built into their experience it will
just be normalized just like you know
children today think that it is just
normal for everybody to have a
smartphone and to you know be navigating
on it and learn how to swipe by the time
they're you know six months old like
like neural interface will just be part
of how they interact with all the rest
of the technology in the environment
well and certainly it seems from our
experience with
um various things that track our
location our preferences over the past
couple decades that people are pretty
darn willing to trade a lot of privacy
for a little convenience is that just my
impression or is that yeah I mean I
think that they're willing to trade just
about all of their privacy for their
convenience but you know it's
interesting because when I talk to
people about brain sensors
it touches a nerve for people so to
speak in a way that it it just doesn't
seem to in other spaces I think
um how freely and easily people give up
their other forms of privacy when you
suggest to them that what they're
thinking or feeling can be decoded and
used it terrifies most people now will
that stay with them will will it be just
as you know um normalized as carrying
around a smartphone that has your GPS
location you know some of my students at
Duke
um they have hundreds of friends in
their like friend sharing Circle that
they share their GPS location with at
all times uh which is amazing to me
right that you would just have like a a
huge number of people who just can track
your every movement
um and the fact that it I mean it's just
it's weird it's different right it's not
it's not how
um I would want to live my life but but
they're very comfortable doing so
um I can imagine something similar
happening already there are forums
online where people are sharing their
brain data with one another and
comparing it and commenting on each
other's brain data
um you know if they're meditating and
they're tracking brainwave data they're
commenting and posting what it looks
like for a previous session and peering
into it and sharing with one another I
just I think I think we're in for a
whole new world with the sharing of
brainwave data yeah okay good and so
let's get into you know the dark
underbelly of this or at least you know
the set of things we should worry about
because I think it goes without saying
we should worry about them now rather
than once it's too late like the
surveillance capitalism
um so if you tell somebody that they can
fly around in the metaverse uh without
even twitching muscles just by thinking
about it and it sounds all fun and
they're ready to do that but then you
tell them that literally all of their
thoughts are being downloaded to Mark
Zuckerberg's hard drive yeah yeah that
sounds scarier and but that's a
plausible I mean that's an exaggeration
but that's the direction of which
they're moving
interaction in which they're moving
right I mean they're moving into a
direction in which the major tech
companies who already have all of their
data are also going to be the ones who
are selling the same devices and so not
only will Google have your search
history but also your brainwave data I
mean that's extraordinary and
um it's something we should worry about
because the commodification of brainwave
data it's not just about you know
sending you very precise advertisements
that same data is sold to employers who
can use it to make hiring and firing and
discriminatory choices about consumers
it can be used to you know identify you
know what you think neuroatypicality is
and precisely discriminate against those
people it can be used by oppressive
governments to test for things like
political ideology and you know make
choices about
how they're going to you know oppress or
repress demonstrations or the likelihood
of people rising up it can be used to
interfere with people's brain activity
whether it's through you know marketing
or trying to addict people to technology
or more frightening using it to try to
disable people's brains on the
battlefield cognitive Warfare is
something that China has recently
declared as you know the kind of next
major Battleground for Humanity and
they're they're investing massive uh
dollars into trying to develop
technology to be able to figure out how
to do that governments are already
interrogating brains uh by bringing in
criminal suspects and using their
brain-based responses to showing them
images or sounds for interrogation
I I find all of this incredibly
frightening there is no safe space for
people to you know think any thoughts
let alone dissident thoughts or
divergent or you know kind of different
thinking and you know I think a lot of
people are talking about the kind of
chilling of freedom of speech and
diversity of ideas and that it's
difficult to really have civil discourse
anymore I worry what that looks like
when even children are afraid to think
differently
and what that ultimately means for truth
and for relationships and for you know
misinformation and disinformation
campaigns
I guess I have one more technology
question that came up as you were saying
because you alluded to it before but I
didn't
seize on it which is this I guess the
cognitive Warfare question or or more
broadly
um or more positively enhancing the
brain so not just passively reading but
actively going in there and improving
your brain or crippling it how worried
should we be about that or how
optimistic should we be about that if we
want to improve our SAT scores
so good questions I'd say I think the
promise of enhancing the brain is huge
um and one of the things that I talk
about in the battle for your brain isn't
just neurotechnology it's all of the
drugs and you know devices and other
ways in which people are able to use the
technology to enhance their brains and
already are
I raised the kind of complicated
question with all of that here at Duke
um cognitive enhancers
if they're taken without a prescription
were made part of the cheating policy at
Duke rather than the drug policy which
is an interesting normative moral choice
right it is to say that using a drug
that enhances your performance is
cheating and you know they didn't really
consult with any of the bioethicists on
campus when they made that choice but
there was a call by students that they
felt like some students were getting
access and that there was distributional
and equality issues about who had access
to the drugs and who didn't have access
to the drugs and it gave some people an
unfair Advantage we're seeing the same
kind of conversations I think right now
around generative AI like chat GPT where
people are worried that the use of those
Technologies both will not be
distributed equally but also that it's
cheating to use them
um I you know I I think it's it's a good
and hard question about whether or not
using enhancing Technologies or
enhancing drugs is cheating but I
generally think that that's kind of what
we're trying to do as human beings we're
trying to enhance ourselves we're trying
to you you know kind of create every
possible way in which we can enhance our
brains and our cognitive experiences and
our effective experiences and so I think
part of what I'm advocating for as
cognitive Liberty is the right to
self-determination which includes the
right to enhance or the right to break
for example if you want to erase painful
memories or you want to treat you know
intractable depression and that requires
in some ways diminishing or breaking
your brain to make that possible I think
the right to self-determination over our
brains and mental experiences is the
full spectrum right it's about being
able to make choices about whether we
enhance our brains or not
but also that to safeguard us from other
people doing it to us without our
consent or our willingness to undergo or
experience that there is a great
philosophy question here because I think
we wouldn't call eating healthy food uh
cheating academically or exercising or
even reading a book
but taking a certain drug counts and
that's probably just a relic of olden
days right that's probably not the right
I mean I think so but there is a
stronghold of people who believe
otherwise right but but I think you know
I think we draw really arbitrary lines
um so you know if I'm if I'm using a
neurofeedback device at home that
decreases my stress level that actually
enhances my performance and well-being
am I cheating because I'm using a
shortcut to do so I'm not good at
meditating without a
um a neurofeedback headset am I
shortcutting you know by doing so I I
think these are
um you know in some ways resistance to
technology but also you know we're maybe
privileging the wrong things the idea
that the genetic Lottery is what we
should you know rely on rather than the
work that people put into actually
enhancing their well-being and their
cognitive States I don't know why we
would just privilege genetic Lottery
over everything else
that is a very good question I did have
a podcast that touched on some of the
things with Catherine page Hardin but I
don't think you know we don't know we
don't have the answers to those
questions yet so I'm glad you brought
them up but but let's get back to you
know uh the dystopia that we're trying
to avoid here
um yes so I can very easily see that
employers maybe even you know
universities seeking to let in students
would want to you know just take a quick
brain scan so we can make sure that
there's no dirty skeletons in your
closet you say that as far-fetched but
it's happening it's happening yeah I
mean I mean not necessarily universities
but you know there are companies like
pymetrics and you know Mercer that that
have cognitive hiring based tools rather
than
um you know companies like higher view
that use like microfacial analysis and
algorithms to try to study people during
remote interviews and
um and so you know is it really so
far-fetched to think that uh the way in
which we would try to make choices
between people would be based on
neurotechnology I don't think so I think
that's that's coming we already see it
in large hiring platforms that are
already trying to do cognitive testing
between individuals and you know there
was already reports of schools
throughout China that were using you
know brainwave headsets on students
while they were in the classroom to see
if they were focused or paying attention
or their mind was wandering so the idea
that
um you know this isn't science fiction
this is here this is the kind of thing
that I think is
um you know happening and going to
continue happening
so I guess the right question to ask is
how far can we go in doing these things
in a completely benign and acceptable
way right like we we wouldn't think that
badly of a company that wanted to give
some
pencil and paper cognitive tests to
prospective employees and maybe cut out
the middleman and just look into their
brains is there you know can you make
the affirmative argument that this is
there's room for this to be good and
useful and safe
yeah maybe if people consent to it I
mean so I'll give you an example there
was a a study that was done that looked
at surgeons and wanted to see whether or
not the tasks like the certification and
and proficiency tasks the skills-based
tasks
um if if those tasks correlated well
with brain activity while the surgeons
were performing the same tasks that they
would perform as part of the
skills-based test and what they found
was that you could very reliably in fact
more reliably than the written test
itself see the difference between the
novice surgeons versus the proficient
and more advanced ones because the
novice ones spent a whole lot more time
thinking about what they were doing and
less brain activity and just the motor
activity are performing what they were
doing and the you know proficient
surgeons were uh you know had spent far
less time thinking about it because it
was habitual it was more automatic for
them and you would see more motor
activity for those individuals when they
were performing the different tasks
you know when you're going to select
your next surgeon are you going to ask
them to put on a uh you know a brainwave
detector and be like listen I don't
really want you spending all your time
thinking about what you're doing I want
you to be really good at this and have
this be like habitual and automatic
um you know but the point is
you know are there ways to use the
technology without being incredibly
oppressive there are but it's not so
easy when it's with a technology like
this that really gets at our innermost
selves
um and and because of that I think we
have to be much much more deliberate
than we have been with the assimilation
of other technology and to our everyday
lives and and I you know again I think I
think we have to start by you know
starting with safeguards in place we
almost always like catch up with
safeguards later or try to regulate
technology later and I just think we
have to start with a basic set of Rights
for people that says like look starting
place of all of this is you have the
basic right to self-determination of
your brain and mental experiences if you
want to opt into this system like yeah
you can opt in there are some great
benefits that you may personally enjoy
if you want to use it in the workplace
to you know improve your focus and
attention but you don't want your
employer to be peering over your
shoulder and using it as boss wear like
you ought to have that right
um and you know but figuring out the
balance this is going to take time this
is going to take a process of democratic
deliberation in society and the first
step to doing that is people have to
become much much more aware much more
sophisticated consumers about technology
that's really crosses that final
frontier of privacy
well and there is a set of things that
I'm sure you're super duper aware of
um
conflicts between freedom and capitalism
and privacy and the right to
self-determination so a company can say
well you can choose voluntarily to take
this cognitive test but if you don't I'm
not going to hire you so what kind of
right to consent is that really
no I agree with you and you know one of
the things I write about in the battle
for your brain is
you know the narrative that people have
often had about workplaces is well you
know if somebody doesn't like a policy
they can just quit and go elsewhere but
that's not true when everywhere does it
and where it becomes the new Baseline
for for what you have to do but that's
why I think if again we flip the
narrative to start with the right to
cognitive Liberty you know the the
really scary stuff comes in when there's
broader things being inferred from our
brain activity than you know kind of
basic things right so if if I'm a
commercial driver and you're picking up
whether I'm sleepy or awake at the wheel
and that is the only thing you're
measuring and you're not taking the rest
of my brainwave data to look and figure
out how I think and feel about a whole
bunch of other things that you have no
business knowing about is it that
invasive to pick up just that one piece
of information and can we create
assurances that that is the only piece
of information that's being picked up I
think that's the kind of thing that a
right to cognitive Liberty would enable
which is to say you have to seek the
except option and the exception has to
be very narrowly tailored to whatever
the purpose is that you're seeking it
for so if you're doing a cognitive test
we do cognitive tests all the time I
mean when I back in back in the day when
I worked at a strategy consulting
company it was oral-based strategy uh
cognitive task right they'd give you a
problem and they'd be like okay here's
the problem you know you have a thousand
whatever like widgets and you want to
figure out how to get them you know into
this area how would you go about doing
it and you have to lay out all of your
mental thinking out loud in order for
them to assess what your mental
processes are like you know if you were
to do the same test with
neurotechnology what are the additional
risks well one of the additional risks
is maybe they discover that the pattern
by which you make those decisions shows
that you're neuroatypical and they use
that to discriminate against you if we
know that and there's no additional
advantage that they get from the
brainwave data that is relevant to
hiring maybe we ought to stick in that
instance with an oral-based tacit that
they can't use other information if it
turns out that the only additional value
for the business would be something that
would have a discriminatory purpose so I
think we've got to look at these things
Case by case and make a decision as a
society starting with a default right
which is you can't use this data against
me right you can't gain access to it
without my permission
and recognize that if it is really that
everywhere has achieved a permission
like every workplace is achieved for
permission it's done so on a really
narrow and limited basis that doesn't
give them access to like broad spectrum
data from our brains
yeah I mean that that does sound like a
very good starting point and but I just
always worry that you know that the
technology moves faster than the law
right so it is you've already identified
this I'm not saying anything I mean look
like like could we put the genie back in
the bottle right I mean I think most
people would be like okay well that's
all well and good but like let's be
honest it's going to get misused
technology gets misused right I mean
that's I am not naive to that I am not
ignorant to the fact that the technology
can and will be misused it can and it
will and it already is being misused I
think the question is given that I think
it is so difficult if not impossible to
put the genie back into the bottle and
that I think that there are real
benefits that people will enjoy from it
um which will lead them to demand the
technology which will lead them to you
know continue to push the development to
the technology forward what's the next
best thing right and I think the next
best thing is like get out ahead of it
by creating some rights that can at
least give us the best chance of
appropriate safeguards at least in
Democratic you know societies like the
United States well yeah I mean you
mentioned China a couple times and I
guess it's probably safe to say to
characterize China as the world's most
technologically advanced autocracy uh so
they're a little bit more willing maybe
than a democracy to experiment with all
these sorts of things but I can never I
have not put in the work to try to
separate the truth from the fiction in
terms of stories about what is going on
in China because there's a lot of
political cultural you know biases that
that push on this but clearly they are
doing more than we are is it is this
kind of thing very prevalent in China
right now are there little test programs
where they're trying things out or do we
just not know
I mean it's hard to know right like it's
hard to get accurate and fair
information about exactly what's
happening what we do know is
um that there are uh you know hundreds
of thousands of these headsets in use
across China and that at least some of
the companies that
um are best known for commodifying brain
data are out of China uh and you know
what will they do with all of that you
know the
um and and how are they using it and
will they misuse it or are they just far
Advanced from all of us you know your
guess is as good as mine but I know that
I personally would not want to be in
China with a headset on
um and I personally you know as an
Iranian American would not want to be in
Iran with a headset on which the
government had access to for the data
do we think that um people are going to
ask potential first dates that they meet
on a dating site to you know sit in a
EEG machine for a little while just to
make sure that they're compatible
I don't know I mean I'll tell you a
little story which is my husband and I
um on our maybe second date compared
23andMe uh profiles to one another
um you know we're weird that way uh but
um you know we laugh about it but it was
you know it was kind of it was kind of
an experiment that was fun
um you know are they likely to to ask
somebody to sit in an EEG headset I
don't think anytime in the near future
but it will become in the nearer Future
something that people geek out about I
mean maybe like you know look at my my
brain session from last week and how
sharp it is or
um you know how how's your meditation
practice versus my meditation practice I
think it's going to be more innocent
sharing like that in the beginning
um it's the kind of thing that you
already see in these online forums where
people are using the technology for
their own benefit but then want to
compare their brain metrics against
another person's brain metrics I can
also Imagine as a lot of these focus and
attention programs are launching that
you know people will compete against one
another like how what's your longest
Focus streak and what's your longest
attention streak or you know things like
that so I I could just see people
gamifying it and then that way sharing a
lot of data with one another I like that
competitive Buddhism you know you're
more and more one with the Universe I
mean it's happening already it's like
like oh how's your gamma activity today
you know yes
but I I could maybe I'm giving away you
know a billion dollar startup idea here
but I love the idea of an app that would
just separately collect the brainwave
data from two people and let you know
ahead of time whether you're compatible
like that's probably actually much more
accurate than the little surveys you do
on OkCupid or whatever maybe I mean you
know we don't know because I think you
would have to like go into
um the gottman love lab and have a whole
bunch of people who have had successful
marriages you know look at what their
brain activity looks like but one thing
that's interesting is
um as people work together over time you
see a lot of synchronous of their brain
activity so you might not know if what
you're seeing is actually they're truly
in sync with one another just because
they've been together for a long time or
this is what would actually lead to them
being in sync together over time so I
don't think we have an answer yet on
like what a neural match looks like but
it'll be interesting to see okay I had
to ask that that was just a fun little
diversion but I guess
um the Capstone here is okay uh we would
like to I'm entirely on board with your
program of enshrining some kind of
privacy rights to your thoughts I mean
it should be our consent to give these
away rather than just being forced by
pressure by jobs by economic pressure to
do it so what how would that work how
would we actually legislate or enshrine
that in some document somewhere
closing an international human right to
cognitive Liberty what that would look
like is the U.N Declaration of Human
Rights already recognizes the three
rights that I think make up cognitive
Liberty at least as a starting place
people may decide that there's more that
needs to go into it over time which
would be reasonable but as a starting
place the right to privacy which is
already an international human right
recognized by the international Covenant
on civil and political rights and signed
on to by all of these different
countries include storage privacy but it
doesn't specify that it includes a right
to mental privacy that can simply be
interpreted by the human rights
committee for example through something
called a general comment to update it
and say this obviously includes the
right to mental privacy and this is what
that would entail freedom of thought
already recognized Again by the U.N
Declaration of Human Rights has
primarily been applied to religious
freedom and hasn't been interpreted to
include a much more robust protection of
freedom of thought the right not to have
your thoughts punished you know used to
punish you not manipulated and used
against you
um the last special repertoire of
freedom of religion Ahmed Shahid
presented a report to the U.N General
Assembly calling for an expanded
understanding of freedom of thought in
October of 2021 wholeheartedly agree
with him we need to update freedom of
thought who really cover all of this
emerging technology and the ability to
really peer into decode misuse your
thoughts against you and then the last
is there is a collective right to
self-determination under the universal
Declaration of Human Rights but there's
never been an individual right to
self-determination that has been
recognized again just by updating our
understanding of the collective right to
self-determination to include food what
has already been recognized which is a
right to informational self-access as
well as a right to self-determination to
be able to change your body as you want
to change your body or not have it
change the way you want it not changed
that right to self-determination over
your brains and mental experiences I
think is critical so all of that can
happen pretty simply the human rights
committee can write a comment that says
the right to cognitive Liberty is
obviously a right that is already
enshrined and the universal Declaration
of Human Rights it requires an updating
of these three existing rights
everybody's already signed on to the
iccpr the international Covenant and
civil and political rights we don't even
need them to all come together and vote
on it right we can just update our
understanding of those things and have a
good starting place are you personally
in contact with the people I am I am yes
I've been presenting this idea across
the UN I've been presenting it to the
human rights committee I've been
advocating for it have given quite a few
presentations to anyone who would listen
I worked closely with the special rep on
freedom of religion as he was writing
his report on freedom of thoughts and
make sure it reflected these ideas about
neurotechnology so it's not some pie in
the sky academic dream about happening
but it's actually you know something
that's underway I think it will require
the political will of people it will
require you know kind of a collective
call for this to show that it really
matters to people and so it's not that
you know we're kind of passive
recipients of updating this right it's
something that each and every one of us
should be act like actively saying like
this is what we require for the coming
future and the future that has already
arrived it might just be a sense of
political exhaustion uh that sits deep
within me over the past few years but I
kind of find it hard to think that the
United States would enact vast new
privacy rights especially when they
might get in the way of certain
companies making money
that might be right
of the Union speech that Biden gave
suggested that there was a you know kind
of increasing call for bipartisan
support for privacy legislation
but again if we start with human rights
right human rights to which we have
already signed on to it already binds
corporations we don't have to
necessarily rely on our divided Congress
coming together and passing
comprehensive privacy legislation
um and you know I guess maybe I'm
naively optimistic here but I I guess I
believe when it comes to people's brains
it's a bipartisan issue that it is hard
to imagine that there is any person on
the left or the right who would think
it's a good idea for corporations and
governments to have unfettered access to
what they're thinking I mean I don't
think politicians could ever run
successfully if we had unfettered access
to what they're actually thinking and
feeling
right but okay so here is
um I'm gonna play the role of the
campaign manager for someone running for
congress and they say look we have a new
technology that will tell us with 99
confidence whether a person is going to
be a terrorist or commit a murder and
they won't let us use it
well but that's not that's
right I mean so mental privacy isn't
absolute there are
um you know a balance of any privacy
interest between social interests and
individual interest and if you add
incredibly compelling evidence that you
had a particular person right for which
that technology would give you all of
the information that you need and it
would be the least intrusive and you
know the Alternatives that you might
employ would be more far more barbaric
and worse to get the information right
it's not impossible to imagine that in
limited national security circumstances
that there would be a justification that
would that would also align with human
rights to use that technology so I don't
think I don't think cognitive Liberty is
a ban on technology I think what
cognitive Liberty is is a respect for
individuals that enables the responsible
progress and use of the technology good
it's just my job to imagine the
nightmare scenarios it's your job to be
optimistic well yeah I guess it's my job
to be optimistic I'm like I'm the person
writing a book about the dystopia who's
optimistic it's funny like it's a any uh
you know juxtaposition between the two
but yes but that scenario makes me think
um I should have asked this earlier but
are we gonna have to do a brain scan
when we check in through security at an
airport someday maybe I mean maybe so I
write about
um the increasing use of Biometrics and
the battle for your brain and and
especially functional Biometrics so it
just turns out that you know passwords
as most people understand are not
particularly secure and they're not a
great way and I don't know about you but
I have a different password for
basically every single site that I have
and so I never know what my password is
and I'm like resetting them on a daily
basis they're also you know given all of
the like
um problems with it increasingly we're
moving to Biometrics right you can
unlock your iPhone with your face or
with your thumb
um and functional Biometrics that is how
you like how you move your fingers right
across the screen or the patterns that
you engage in functionally are better
Biometrics for security than just static
ones like a face print where somebody
could take like an image of your face
and use it and brain biome metrics are
quite powerful for authentication of
individuals that is like you could sing
a little ditty in your head like pick
your favorite song
um and record your brain activity while
you are singing that little ditty in
your head and then the next time that
you want to unlock your computer or
unlock you know access to your
employment site or anything else you
would sing that same little song in your
head and your unique pattern of
brainwave activity and singing that song
is different than how I would sing that
exact same song
um and given that brain Biometrics May
increasingly be used by governments as a
way to authenticate individuals
but now you have a new dystopia which is
that I have to like hum Jingle Bells to
myself every time I want to log on to it
better song
you know how about like Rihanna diamonds
or something like you know pick a good
song that you hum in your head so that
you don't have to you know have a jingle
like Jingle Bells stuck in your head all
year long
so it's yeah I I can you tell me a
little bit about
um so you said you've been talking to
people they're they're receptive you
know the people who have the ability to
you know think about these things
um what is the level of awareness of
this problem on the part of the typical
National politician
well typical National politician
probably not that high okay
um but at the international human rights
level I think there's a lot of awareness
of what's Happening
um and in a lot of international
settings there's been a lot of an
awareness about what's happening and I'm
not the only person advocating for
changes in this space there are
activists who have started to talk about
the different set of rights that we need
as neurotechnologies and Neuroscience
progresses and so there's been a lot of
activity for example at the oecd the
um who have you know proposed
regulations of neurotechnology and
there's been the Council of Europe who's
taken up the issue and different
committees within the UN that have taken
up the issue and so you know across the
kind of international
human rights landscape as well as kind
of increasingly from some you know
active folks across Academia from you
know lots and Neuroscience to philosophy
to computer science you see a lot of
people starting to raise the alarm Bells
about the center to really start to say
like hey this is we need to be on high
alert and we need to do something about
it now so I think I see activity
coalescing around raising Consciousness
and also advocating for different
solutions to the problem or set of
problems that we see uh and that's
promising the average like if I were to
you know have gone to the State of the
Union recently and you know picked my
favorites
um congresswoman and said like hey what
do you think about the emerging Trends
and you know brain sensors I would think
I would get a very Blank Stare okay but
maybe they have a staffer who is aware
maybe they have a staffer who's on it
and I hope I hope they do yeah so I
actually do like to always end the
podcast on an optimistic note so and it
sounds like you're you're primed to do
this you've already been pushing the
optimistic line that but I'll let you
sort of just
um you know sum it up somehow but there
is a future in which we take advantage
of this technology and it makes our
lives more convenient and gives us
access to things you wouldn't otherwise
have without selling the farm and giving
away our innermost terrible thoughts to
the whole world
there is
um so I I will sound
cautiously optimistic and say
um
I believe that it is difficult if not
impossible to ban Technologies and that
that isn't in the best interest of
humanity that there can be great promise
from neurotechnology for individuals to
improve their own health and well-being
and that when empowered to make choices
for themselves about how they use the
technology that it can be a force of
good it can help us transcend you know
neurological disease and disorders even
improve our mental health when there is
a crisis of mental health across the
world it also has the risk of becoming
the most dystopian technology we've ever
Unleashed on society and so we have
choices we can make right now that help
shape the direction that the technology
will take and those choices Begin by
recognizing a right to cognitive Liberty
the right to self-determination over our
brains and mental experiences and there
couldn't be a more urgent call to action
because truly what's at stake is what it
means to be human and so it's a call to
action for everybody to become aware but
also advocates for those rights for
themselves and for society
I cannot improve upon that need Affair
honey thanks so much for viewing the
mindscape podcast thank you for having
me it's been a pleasure
[Music]